when you escaped and you when you went
to uh
china and eventually south korea
what was that experience like i've read
some horrific things that you
experienced
when you were going there with the
experience of having to bury your own
father
at 3 a.m in the morning and you and your
mother
being attacked by men and asking to
you know trying to rape you and it's
you again you you listen to these
stories and one on one end
you don't want to hear these stories
because it's so hard to listen to
stories especially as a man who has a
kid and
i'm married i got three kids i got a
daughter and i'm just thinking about
those thoughts but at the same time if
you don't talk about it
then the people around the world are not
going to realize how bad things are so
it's very
conflicted because i'm sure you don't
enjoy talking about the stuff regularly
because it's constant re-reminder
so if you don't mind if you're
comfortable sharing with that do you
mind sharing with us what were some of
those things that happened to you on
your way to south korea
i know i think i'm so grateful what you
just mentioned like you
actually when you began our interview
you said like oh this is a story that
what
cnn or msnbc or fox doesn't talk about
right
in two right now in china in 2020
there are about 300 north korean
defectors in china
right now are hiding
and being sold as a human slaves right
now
and i was one of them we hear about this
boko haram girls
we talk about these girls captured by
isis
we give the nobel peace prize and we
know these girls exist
but we don't talk about the women who
are being sold
like the isis like captures in china
because
china is um everyone has economic
interest in china
in in this world right now so they
purposely ignore us that we exist and
so when i escaped to china in 2007
i was 13 years old my sister few days
before me
escaped i wanted to go with her but
because i had a very bad stomachache
my parents took me to hospital but you
know in north korea we don't have like
x-ray machines and see what's wrong with
you literally just doctor rub your belly
and say oh my god i think he she got
some like appendix
she needs to do the surgery right now
otherwise it's gonna pop this afternoon
so that afternoon they cut my belly open
without any painkiller
and then like what they found was not
even appendix it was just like
infection and malnutrition that's why i
had a very bad stomach ache
and they still like removed my appendix
i always keep fainting and
it's a very common thing we just do
surgery like no painkiller in north
korea they like cut bones when there's
no painkiller
and then and what shocked me the most is
like
nurse in the hospital she literally uses
a one meter
to inject everybody and like you use
like
hair butters to add like a drop
and you see like um dead bodies
writing from house bitter like piled up
and you know you see like rats eating
human eyes first
and you still kids chasing those rats
because even rats are very precious like
protein and kids eat those rats but
those rats have some infection by eating
human flesh at her
the kids die then vets get us back
and and that's the point we thought like
we gotta get out of here even if we die
on the journey we are going to get out
of here so my sister
escaped at 16 with her friend
and few days later as soon as i got out
of the hospital
my mom and i followed her to china
through a broker but we didn't ask why
this broker was helping us
we were so desperate we didn't even like
it didn't really matter why that person
was helping us
we were dying anyway so we crossed the
frozen river to
from china to and north korea to china
but
when i started for crossing it's like it
sounds very easy crossing the river
right but
every few meters in north korea inside
there are guards with machine guns
standing there
and they have the shoot to kill order so
if they see anyone crossing the frozen
river
you don't even ask you don't need to
even ask them to wait
you can just shoot them and that is the
order from the regime
but the broker that we were following
had like drive the guards on that spot
so we were able to cross it without
getting shot but if you want to cross
without broker you're going to get shot
that's why
most of north kings cannot escape
as soon we arrived in china side the
first thing i was saying
my mom was being raped by this chinese
broker
and he was trying to rape me but i just
got up like i was like
something 60 something pounds i'm still
like 80 pounds but i was like way
smaller
and my mom was protecting me and then
they said
if you want to survive in china you have
to be soared
as sexual slaves
it was 2007 like 21st century
i never thought like we can serve human
beings like dogs like
puppies right they were these chinese
brokers came
negotiating our price like real like a
puppies
on the market and my mom was sold for
india's 21st century for 65 dollars
like less than my phone in my hand and
my price was
higher than hers over 200
because i was a virgin so
they paid less than three hundred
dollars to buy me
and separating me from my mom so i was
got separated from my mom at 13
right there she started to farmer
and they sorted me out to another broker
and the man who bought me he he he was
already married he was a lot older than
me but he said
oh i want to keep you you're a virgin
most of north korean girls actually by
the time they go to the second broker
they all raped so nobody's virgin
but i fought so hard with the first
broker that he wasn't able to
successfully to reign me
so the second broker got me as a virgin
i was very precious
for that market i was 13 and virgin
he wanted to kill me for himself and i
was going to kill myself
and he said oh if you become my mistress
i'm going to bring your parents to me to
me that he was going to save my parents
for me
and i thought oh if i sacrifice myself i
can save my father i can save my mom
that's how i became his mistress at 13
and he bought my mom from a farmer
that he sold previously and brought my
sick father
from north korea but my father
was in a in a prison camp and tortured
and got a
colon cancer he couldn't make it uh
and passed away three months later
and that's when i had to bury his ashes
in the middle of night in china because
chinese authority catch us and send us
back north korea to be killed
even though that goes against geneva
convention
that goes against any international law
that should protect political prisons
like escapees because
north koreans are not just like economic
migrants
when we escape that means we defy the
regime
and we become political like uh
refugees so the china has a
responsibility to protect us but they
capture us
and send us back north korea so we can
be executed and tortured and sent to
prison camp
the only reason only way for north korea
to survive in china is hiding and being
sold and being raped
eventually i walked across the
scobie desert from mongolia from china
to mongolia
in 2009 with my mom and that's
how i became from from mongolia to south
korea
but right now there are still girls like
me 10
15 years old even 10 years old are being
sold in china
but nobody mentions about these women
exists
because we don't want to upset chinese
regime
because they are the almighty god now
they got this economic power
you